If knowledge doesn't soften you, then what is it doing for you?
Some people think knowledge automatically makes you better, but the Qur'an shows that knowledge can also
inflate the ego and ruin a person depending on who they are.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives us a story of Qarun, a man with wealth, influence and
knowledge and yet it became his downfall.
He was wealthier than any wealthy person you can imagine in the world today.
قَالَ إِنَّمَا أُوْتِيْتُهُ عَلَىٰ عِلْمٍ عِنْدِي He said, I was given all of this because of
knowledge that I have.
Meaning, I did this.
My intellect. Look at that sentence.
No gratitude, no humility, no recognition that Allah is the source of provisions.
That's how some leaders get corrupted.
They started believing that their gifts or privileges are proof of them being superior to others.
And here's a Qur'anic leadership principle.
Knowledge must produce humility.
Otherwise, a person may become prideful.
Leadership thinkers and experts will say something similar.
Competence without character can become a leadership hazard.
People don't follow knowledge alone.
They follow trust. They follow sincerity.
They follow ethics and principles and the Prophet ﷺ taught us to ask for beneficial knowledge
and also to fear, to ask for protection against knowledge that doesn't help us.
قَالَ اللَّهُ مَا إِنِّي أَعُوذُ بِكَ مِنْ عِلْمٍ لَا يَنْفَعُ Allah says, I seek refuge with
you from knowledge that does not benefit us.
And of course asking for قَالَ اللَّهُ مِنْ يَسْأَلُكَ عِلْمًا نَافِعًا Allah says, I seek refuge
with you from knowledge that does not benefit us.
I want beneficial knowledge of Allah.
Because the goal is not just information.
The goal is transformation.
And we see this in the world sometimes today.
People know a lot.
They may quote a lot.
They may speak confidently.
But they might be very arrogant and harsh and dismissive and obsessed with being right.
And the Qur'an is warning you.
If knowledge doesn't soften you, then what is it doing for you?
One day knowledge will not impress Allah ﷻ by itself.
It will either be a proof for you or against you.
حُجَّةٌ لَكَ أَوْ عَلَيْكَ Hujjatun laka aw alayk So take two actions today.
Before you correct someone, ask yourself.
Am I trying to guide someone to something better or am I trying to win?
And make a du'a today and every single day.
Oh Allah, grant me beneficial knowledge and protect me from harmful knowledge, useless information.
Remember that knowledge that doesn't humble you can also harm you.
And that the sign of guidance is a softer heart and nearness to Allah.
Leave a comment below.
What are some of the things that help people to focus on beneficial information and knowledge
and how to put it into practice with humility and not arrogance?
And of course if this has benefited you in any way then share it with others
in order to remind them as well.
May Allah bless you all.